lady bird ist das land aufnahme ja warum
steht ja in anführungszeichen ich habe
ihn mir ausgesucht der name wurde mir
von mir gegeben wird sagt immer dass sie
neben der bahn lebt ich hab gedacht ist
eine metapher dabei gibt es da
tatsächlich eine richtige bahn strecke
eigentlich aber ganz unauffälliger film
und umso dringender meine empfehlung
geben sich anzuschauen weil er so gar
nicht so völlig unspektakulär daher
kommen du machst es echt abgefahren
ziemlich anarchie legt das heft wieder
zurück spielt ein junges mädchen das
argument im letzten schuljahr
traditionell wird darüber legt in
welches college geht und so seine zeit
der veränderungen dorthin wo kultur ist
warum meine tochter bloß diesen
connecticut oder new hampshire werden
schriftstellern ja gar nicht auf diese
uni schaffen
dialoge sind wirklich auf den punkt
geschrieben
die szenen sind sehr kurz brechen dann
ab unter umständen mit seiner kleinen
konnte ein teil des films verbringen
christi mit einem gipsarm weil die sich
so über ihre modelle dass sie das sagt
ich kann es gar nicht mehr aushalten
gemacht die tür auf und diese dynamik
zwischen diesen beiden spielen der
älteren die jüngeren gibt eigentlich in
dem die fünf schon so viel energie wie
man den anderen filmen eben durch
äußeren bewegungen
an ständen bekommt es das normale alter
für 6 3 6
es gibt die ersten liebhaber eine davon
timothée salami die wir in kombi variant
gesehen habe ja so zart und intelligent
und liebenswert ist und hier ist ja
eigentlich ziemlich es ich wollte das
besonders
warum
fast noch so oft an besonderen fest im
leben haben wächst so auf in diesem
gefühl sie kann eigentlich alles machen
obwohl ihre finanziellen mittel relativ
begrenzter einer mathe olympiade
antreten aber in mathe bist du nicht
unbedingt die stärkste nur nach jetzigem
stand selber in diesem gefühl
aufgewachsen ganz offensichtlich dass
die welt auf sie wartet
die eier sind nicht dort bitte mach dir
deine scheiße ich wollte aber ich durfte
mich sind das tolle figur zu sehen
diese völlig ungebunden ist von
standardisierten vorstellungen oder in
der generation vorher noch
standardisierten vorstellungen davon
also mitgemacht ich wünsche mir für dich
dass du die allerbeste version von dir
selbst werden kannst
und was man dass die beste version
ich denke jetzt eigentlich wirklich im
film für zuschauer in diesem alter also
zwischen 17 und 21 oder so klar aber
auch für die älteren generation